James: This is a video of me, falling in love.
It’s only 9 seconds long, which is why we’re
having to loop it again and again.
I didn’t know that much about it compared
to everything I know now.
I barely even knew how to look at it properly.
But I knew that it was beautiful, and that
I wanted to see more.
Hank: That is James, who many of you know
as our master of microscopes.
He is the scientist—
and I would also say the artist—
behind just about everything we are able to
see in our collective journey through the microcosmos.
Now some of you may know the story
of how that journey got started.
How I, Hank Green, saw James’ work online
and then reached out to him to see if he would
want to start this channel together.
When I saw the videos he posted, the thing
that got me most excited was what I…
didn’t know.
I feel like most people have some vague sense
that tardigrades are cool, and that single
celled organisms, exist…
but when I was watching James’ videos, I
never knew what I was looking at.
I didn’t have any categories to place these
things into.
I felt like I was watching unnarrated footage
from a nature documentary…
of another planet, and that is a feeling
that I liked quite a lot.
Luckily, James decided to let us join in on
his journey, sharing his videos and knowledge
so that we could pull more people into the
microcosmos.
But James’ journey was already well
underway before we found his content,
and today we want to learn
more about that path.
Because here on Journey to the Microcosmos,
we’ve had the chance to explore the history
of microscopy through the lives of former
masters.
But microscopy isn’t some ancient field
contained only in dusty books.
It is still evolving through the work of
students and scientists and hobbyists who
are finding new paths through microscopy today.
For James, love began maybe where
you’d least expect it.
James: I was taking a lab course on wastewater
treatment.
Yes, I know it sounds disgusting, and it was.
We had jars full of human waste, and then
we had to look at those samples under the
microscope to see what creatures were growing
in there.
And I thought it was going to be boring.
But then I put a drop of that slimy stuff
onto a slide, placed the coverslip on top,
and looked at it under the microscope.
And it was like love at first sight.
I couldn’t believe what I was seeing.
I remember seeing something that looked like
a worm with a chainsaw mouth, which took me
completely by surprise.
I had no idea what I was looking at, but later
I learned it was a rotifer.
I went into the course knowing absolutely
nothing about microbes, but I came out of
it knowing that a few hours of microscopy
in a class weren’t enough for me.
I had to get my own microscope, even though
it was a big expense for a poor student.
And while I waited for it to arrive, I spent
hours and hours studying everything I could
find about microbes.
Hank: Many of the organisms that we get to
watch with James come from the Polish ponds
close to where he lives.
But the first sample he ever studied under
his own microscope came from a puddle close
to his home.
And the video of peritrich ciliates that we
opened the video with, that is the first thing
he recorded on it.
James: I have so much from that first week
of microscopy to look back on.
I had learned enough about peritrich ciliates
in my course work to identify them in my first slide.
But other creatures were harder for me, like
this little green guy.
I spent all night looking up pictures of algae
only to accidentally stumble on an organism
I’d never heard of before called a desmid,
and after hours of Googling, I realized that
this was a desmid.
It’s funny remembering how much time it
took me to realize I was looking at a desmid
because they are super common.
Finding one and identifying it is like identifying
a cow in a field full of cows.
But I found really unusual things in that
first week of microscopy, like these giant
purple amoeba that I haven’t been able to
find again since.
And then there were odd things like these
Thecamoeba that I didn’t even think were
microbes at first.
It was all so confusing to understand, but
it became easier and easier the more I learned.
Hank: These early videos, you know, they
might not be James’ finest work.
He’s holding a camera close to the eyepiece
with his hand, so sometimes things are a little
shaky or blurry.
So for those of us who have gotten used to
the clarity of his footage,
this is a different experience.
But that’s what makes these older videos
for me so fascinating.
The work James produces now is so incredible
to look at that it’s easy to take the work
going into them for granted, to assume that
the microcosmos simply looks like that all
of the time.
The fascinating organisms he finds, the vivid
tableaus they paint across our screen—
those belong to the microcosmos.
But they’re revealed to us through skills
that James has been honing for hours and hours
every day since he studied
these first early slides.
Those are hours that build up into years of
finding the right places to sample, of devising
new strategies to house those samples and
keep the organisms inside them alive.
And then hours spent fine-tuning his skills
on the microscope, understanding what techniques
to use to bring different layers of the microcosmos
to life.
James: I think microscopy provides me with
creative ideas.
Everything becomes a question of
“Can I use this in microscopy?”
For example, I heard once that hydras are
often found in aquariums.
So I went to some pet stores, bought some
aquatic plants, and set up my first microbe tank.
The aquatic plants came with some snails.
One day when I was looking at a snail under
the microscope, I found this green hydra stretching-off
of the snail’s shell!
And that’s the beauty of the microcosmos,
you can find the things you’re looking for
in places you’d never expect to find them.
And later, I created a YouTube channel to
share some of my videos with my professor,
and I realized that I love recording videos
of microbes.
I’m kind of like a hoarder of microscopy
footage.
Hank: James isn’t kidding about that…
he estimates that he has more than 5000 hours
of footage now.
You could watch all ten Fast and Furious movies
269 times in 5,000 hours, and despite Vin
Diesel’s best intentions, it would probably
not produce nearly as much drama and heartbreak
as what James has recorded.
James: The more I learned, the more excited
I got about microbes.
I contacted scientists to start volunteering
in labs.
I shared more videos on YouTube.
I posted what I found on reddit.
And then one day, one of my videos went viral
and that’s how Hank found me.
Hank: And sharing his work helped James find
one of his most important collaborators and mentors:
Dr. Genoveva Esteban, a professor in microbiology
at Bournemouth University who has been studying
ciliates for decades.
Ciliates are single-celled eukaryotes known
for the hair cilia that cover their bodies,
and James had become particularly interested
in them.
Ciliates are a very, very diverse group of
organisms, including everything from this
Dactylochlamys to our favorite trumpet-like
Stentors.
And it turned out that thanks to his persistent
sampling, James had a real knack for finding
very rare ciliates.
James: In one of my favorite places, I found
this weird ciliate.
I didn’t know that Professor Esteban was
following my work, but she messaged me to
ask me about the super rare microbe I was
finding.
And even though she has been in this field
for so long, she had never seen a species
like this.
So we started texting about microbes, and
over time, we talked more and more about rare
microbes and the interesting ciliates we were
finding.
And now we even publish papers together.
When I found the extremely rare Legendrea
loyezae, she was the first person I called.
I remember pacing around
in circles in my living room,
telling her all about the tentacles extending.
Hank: There are always all sorts of lessons
you can take from a story like James’.
His persistence, his love for his craft, the
joy of microscopy.
But there’s something else too: community.
So much of James’ story is about being alone,
hours spent hunched over a microscope.
But so much of it is also about not being
alone, about finding people who share his
love for the microcosmos, and even people
who don’t know yet that they share that love.
There are people he talks to every day about
microbes like Professor Esteban.
There are people he regales in meetings with
funny stories about the absurd lengths he’s
gone to for his microbes, like those of us
on the Journey to the Microcosmos team.
And there are even people he doesn’t know,
like many of you.
With every video, we get to see through his
eyes a little bit and journey to another world,
individuals brought together by a beam of
light wielded by a master’s hands.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you are interested in beginning your own
microscopy journey,
you can head over to microcosmos.store
where we’ve got all of the stuff you need
to get started including microscopes, slides,
and even a micro bumper sticker that says
“Tardigrade Enthusiast” so you can let
everyone around you know that if they’re
out there searching for a person who shares
their love of the Microcosmos, you are that
person.
And speaking of people who share that love,
these on the screen right
now are the names of our Patreon patrons.
These are the folks who have made it possible
for us to go on this wonderful journey that,
I have been so happy to have been included
on.
So thank you to all of them for being such
a huge part of what we do.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.